[Music]
good afternoon
congratulations to our graduates
it's a privilege for me to be able to
share a few words on this
wonderful occasion graduations are
important milestones no matter when they
take place
but your graduation will always be
exceptional
for over a year we have walked a strange
and
historic path together we're now at the
end of an academic year like
no other but although our traditions may
look different this year
they are just as meaningful as ever
commencement is a time of celebration
it is a chance for you to revel in your
accomplishments
it is also an opportunity to reflect
and say thank you so many people have
been a part
of your journey to this moment
i hope you will find the time to tell
them
how much they have meant to you
i would also like to say thank you to
you
day after day for more than a year you
have made
sacrifices for the greater good
you have studied and conducted research
under extraordinary circumstances
you have helped keep our neighbors on
campus and a new haven safe
and it has not been easy
like people around the world you have
experienced
loss grief and uncertainty
and yet you have repaid our communities
trust
and confidence in you many times over
now as you look to the future
to your lives beyond jail and hopefully
beyond this moment
i'd like to share a personal story
it is a story about my past and present
but i share it because i hope it will
shed some light
on your future
it is about teachers and the gifts
they give us
in the early 1970s i was a student
at williamsville high school north
outside of buffalo
new york it was a pretty typical large
public high school
we had a popular football team and a
marching band that
played at games perhaps it will surprise
you to learn that
i did not play on the football team but
i did march with the band
and you might wonder how i fit into a
school like this i actually earned
a varsity letter for the drama club
i was also part of another student
organization
as well a poetry club hosted by
two beloved english teachers mr and mrs
blaisdell
a group of us would gather in their home
and share poems we had written
or come across we drank coffee
we talked about poetry it was all very
grown up
especially for kids like us from buffalo
our teachers were only in their 20s
perhaps early 30s
but they were sophisticated adults and
therefore seem much older to us
they care deeply about literature
writing
and poetry but most of all
they care about us their students
in fact i'm not the only student of the
blaisdells on the faculty here at yale
they taught english to chemistry
professor scott miller about a decade
after me
fast forward 46 years
the kids from that poetry club now have
families and
careers of their own a surprising number
of them are now
college or university professors
we've stayed in touch but usually we
only see each other every few years at
best
as a way of coping with the social
isolation of the pandemic
we started meeting over zoom
we shared poems we drank coffee together
again our former english teachers from
williamsville north
now retired joined us
and we found in the midst of so much
grief and loneliness
a way to connect
what does this mean for you first
it's my hope that each of you have made
a friend here perhaps a few friends
who will be there for you in 46 years
that's no small thing second
i hope you found great teachers
who will continue to advise and guide
you
for years to come and third
i hope you are leaving yale ready to
become those teachers and mentors to the
next generation
i recently had the privilege of
interviewing poet louise glick
she won the nobel prize in 2020 for
literature
professor glick has taught at yale since
2004.
she told me she thinks of teaching as a
way of repaying her debts
you can't thank your teachers she said
except by performing as they did
for another generation
now not all of you will become educators
but you can of course repay your
teachers
by sharing your curiosity and love of
learning
with the world you came to yell because
you wanted to ask questions and
search for answers some of you have
prepared for professions in fields like
nursing or law
or the arts others have earned a
master's degree or a phd that will take
your expertise into universities
laboratories
and workplaces throughout the united
states and the world
all of you are leaving here with gifts
from your teachers
what are these gifts for my teachers i
learned to ask different questions
bigger questions
in high school i was always trying to
figure out what a poem was about
i wanted to unlock the secret meaning
but mr blaisdell would tell me peter
what the poem is about is not always the
most interesting question
he encouraged me to appreciate beauty
and occasionally put aside analysis
he pushed me to use different parts of
my mind
and my emotions
teachers throughout my life including my
professors in graduate school here at
yale
shared with me their deep and joyful
love
of learning they modeled curiosity and
resilience
they introduced me to interests that
have made my life richer
and more rewarding
it is now your time to serve as a model
for the next generation of scholars
practitioners
and professionals that
is how we repay our teachers
over the past year we have learned so
much about ourselves
and about what we are capable of
and we've been reminded again and again
that we must keep
learning there will always be new
challenges to tackle
unexpected problems to solve we will
have to pivot
and adapt and if we love learning if we
are
curious about the world and the people
in it then that
task will be so much easier and more
fulfilling
in the book tuesdays with maury the
sports writer mitch album describes
reconnecting with his former professor
maury schwartz the elderly maury is
suffering with als
lou gehrig's disease and the book
is an extended reflection on life and
death
but it is also about the relationship
between a student and his teacher
at the end album says have you ever
really had a teacher one who saw you
as a raw but precious thing
a jewel that with wisdom
could be polished to a proud shine
if you are lucky enough to find your way
to such teachers
you will always find your way back
i hope you find your way back back to
your teachers
and back to yale i hope you will return
to campus and walk down
chapel street and enjoy the sunshine or
the snow
on old campus or science hill
and i hope you will find ways of sharing
the joy of discovery with others
i hope you share your curiosity with a
world
that needs questions as much as answers
that needs light and truth
more than ever
i usually conclude my addresses on
commencement weekend with a few words of
verse
and over the years i've read from
rabindranath tagore
elizabeth alexander billy collins marie
boroff
claudia rankin but most
often i have turned to the words of john
milton
from paradise lost you know those verses
about leaving the garden of
eden with wandering steps and slow
and making one's way into a world that
is all before you
there are moments when those lines move
me to tears
and in this challenging year paradise
just doesn't seem like the right
metaphor
for our beloved campus but i look ahead
with great optimism
and i trust you do too
so perhaps the words of emily dickinson
seem more appropriate at this moment
hope is the thing with feathers that
perches in the soul
and sings the tune without the words and
never stops
at all my friends
you are ready to face the future with
optimism
and determination you are ready to repay
the gifts your mentors have given you
and share the joy of discovery
with others you go with our best wishes
and admiration congratulations
and good luck
you